in just one County in Long Island in
just one day
police medics are getting more than 140
kovat 19 call-outs it's constantly
nothing but sorrow that's on the phone
it's a stressful time it's a time that
we need to unite and work together and
what do we not hear in Nassau County
unfortunately this is the week that they
say this surge is coming it's not like
you're gonna see it it's just they're
gonna be basically numbers and you can
feel it ambulances everywhere each
report
treated as a possible covert case there
are new rules new risks new pressures
and no one knows when any of those will
ease we're now seeing people that we
know there's a really good chance our
not gonna make it past a couple days or
a couple weeks or even out of the
hospital
back in New York City they're
considering temporarily burying victims
of the virus on an island extreme
measures after the deadliest 24 hours
yet in the state behind every one of
those numbers is an individual as a
family as a mother as a father as a
sister as a brother that Mount Sinai
Hospital in South Nassau experienced
disease doctors are stunned well it's
it's as distressing as any of us I've
ever dealt with in my entire
professional career as an infectious
disease physician for over 30 years it
is a devastating loss of life it is
devastating to families economically
emotionally spiritually there may be
seeing a leveling off of hospital
admissions in New York City but here
there are a good few days behind that
and with more data has come more
evidence of deaths the numbers rising
sharply five hundred people have died
here and supplies are running low it's
desperate it's desperate we're getting
donations we're buying we're getting
from
State in the federal government but
anytime we get some in we get it out as
quickly as possible and then there's
just this gaping need for more more
equipment more people more patients
because no one here can assume they're
through the worst of it
Cordelia Lynch Sky News Nassau County
Long Island